Wow, you're hangry chef was like
the, he was like the beginning.
It happened before that old NBA
people will be like, that's bullshit.
They didn't the 70s but Shaq was just
the biggest guy that's ever played with
that much agility. Whenever I shake his
hand I'm like, what is that? It's absurd.
Yeah. It's like a desk. It's like shit.
He's like, hey man, what's
up? How you doing Joe pig for,
he did fear factor with me and him.
Him and I were like,
he was a huge fear factor fan.
Yeah,
so he did like a whole episode where he
co hosted it with me and he stood next
to me and he like he would do,
I'm going to do the countdown to
shock attack and when he
would do the countdown,
almost standing next to him like this is
like an eight year old hanging out with
his, his dad. Oh all. I hear
stories like that that he's like,
he's a big kid on set. They can
like, he can't stop fucking around.
I felt an eight year old who grown up.
He's so big.
He's a big kid. That's all I
ever hear. Anybody who works
with him, like he fucked,
he loves fucking around. He loves
not taking it serious. Super Fun guy.
Very friendly. He's so dynamic.
He's like a cop. Yeah. He,
he wants to do like undercover work
for in Miami or something. Right.
Workflow for Laura or some shit.
He uh,
he would be involved in raids and Shit
and pretty hard to be undercover when
you're six 11. I thought this
massive black dude, he's,
he's gotta be one of the
biggest guys that's ever
played. Right. Not the tallest,
but probably one of the most, probably
the most mass. Yeah. And Muscle. I mean,
you know, when you get up next to
his arm, it's, it's, it's this,
it's like two of my thighs. He got
into MMA for awhile. Diddy, yeah.
I don't know if he's trying
to doing it. Yeah. Training.
But there was videos of him
training and I'm just like, look,
if there was no weight limitations,
like he's so good.
Look at that and him together.
So fucking big. Yeah. This,
that does look like it's like
a man in his buddy child child.
And a grown man. Yeah. I have a picture.
I have a picture of me at the MTV.
What was it at move your
words or something like
that with him next to me and
where I was interviewing him for this
thing and he will always be the roast one
of the road, a Bieber and I'm in and
I'm doing this with the microphone,
like full extension with it and he's
bending down still. You still has to Doug.
I'm like it check. It's kind of weird
that like the UFC has a weight limit,
like what's the top out to 65 yeah.
Isn't that weird? Yeah. Why is that?
I don't know. Does it get, there's a
hit. There's a super heavy, super heavy,
we've never had a super heavy fight,
but super heavyweight is to 65 and above.
Well,
who's the heaviest fighter that's ever
fought to 65 when they weigh in after
that probably Brock Brock was a cut and
wait to make two 65 wasn't he around 300
pounds? I'll for sure.
That's fucking insane.
And it's a different kind of 300
pounds to Shaq is three 37 and 41
his shoes are 2122 they're almost to,
his foot is two feet.
That's his foot. That's how fucking
bit, yeah, his foot is two feet. Jesus.
But like a guy like that could never
fight in the UFC cause you probably can't
make two 65 no.
If he did,
you'd be sure fucking zero zero fat.
I want,
but I wonder about how because he's so
big, he'd have to lose 75 pounds, right?
They say three thirties I already weighed.
Yeah,
three 30 they look like as a rookie.
Oh my God.
He was so big, so big. And, and they,
and he's a kid right there by the way.
He's,
he's put 20 or 19 or 20 years old
right there. God Damn, that's crazy.
It's a fucking full grown man at 20
I mean, what, did you ever see them,
do you ever seen movie blue chips? Do you
ever see that? No. That's a great movie.
It's like about about Shaq.
Nick Nolte.
He's recruiting him od
shack. Yeah, it's fun.
It's a phenomenon you would,
and he would love Volti what?
How good is that guy was awesome. Oh,
he's so good in this fucking movie.